I'm going to talk about we got sort of a
friendly slash extortion email
apparently someone has photos of you in
Manchester United Jersey and we would
all like an explanation really being
that year such a die-hard Arsenal fan
and your gunner for life how dare you
roam the streets in a man you Jersey I'm
gonna tell you a little story little
girl and okay and y'all y'all better
listen to you bet y'all better not okay
your choice your choice okay but is this
is the reason I [ __ ] got into soccer
in the [ __ ] first place he's because
of FIFA okay
my brother and I didn't know anything
about soccer until 2006 what we did was
we had I had a PlayStation mm and my
brother goes we should try sports game
and I hate I don't know how hockey's
played I don't like football American
football and my brothers like soccer is
easy maybe what is it how do you play it
like that's how little I knew about
soccer you just kick the ball in any way
you play it it was yeah kick the ball
and we bought it it was a 2006 road to
the World Cup so it was only in
international teams gotcha but some of
the players had stars above their heads
and those were the ones I had that makes
especial gay nineties plus like Rooney
would have won bekommen would have won
or whatever right and then you kind of
and then there was one guy that was so
good on the French team and it was
honoring okay carry on replayed for
arsenal oh the black guy yes yeah Andre
is a legend yeah so I would watch him to
beat my brother but on TV so I would
look him up on the internet or I would
watch like you know that's Fox Sports
sports would have like classic games or
whatever and I would watch him and then
I would also watch man you because of
the fact that gee some Park was a part
of it and also schools gigs and I liked
last of 92 yeah so what may
point is is that I liked both of them I
was a fan of both Arsenal and menu but
what happened with menu was Park left
skulls retired gigs retired and then Sir
Alex Ferguson left the team and then
after that I'm like I have no
attachments wasn't your team anymore
yeah and it was man you was my I mean
Arsenal was my team and from now on
Arsenal will always be my team you know
so that's the story on that what if Sir
Alex Ferguson came back does it matter
wait is it true that josie marino is
going to menu he already signed also van
Gaal's yeah yeah oh god okay and is it
also true that Jamie Vardy
is it says that he for twenty million
dollars he wants to go to any of the
Champions League team so that's either
Arsenal he's already in a Champions
League team why did he say that then I
don't know what you're talking about
when you said the last time like what
are you talking about no so it's either
it's either Arsenal
no not Lester Lester I know cuz there's
number one you're automatically gonna go
right yeah so why would I think ABS
Champions League team why I don't know
it doesn't make any sense we I've never
heard of that before
what is read up on it if there's nothing
like that on there it's for 20 million
euro you read it wrong Bobby pulled
someone even bought the weapon please
don't please don't
Bobby if you Oh Bobby Bobby is [ __ ]
uppercut you bro face go ahead try it
alright speaking of uppercut yeah big
event happening in LA this weekend
[Music]